Ich habe mich unheimlich über eure vielen themenvorschläge bei whatsapp gefreut und auch dieses hochspannende thema hier kommt von euch ihr wollt mehr erfahren über
technische fortschritte die unser leben immer sicherer machen und menschenleben retten angefangen bei
argumente duelle tief für die feuerwehr bis zu computern die
krankheiten besiegen wie das alles funktioniert und wie viele menschenleben gerettet werden können jetzt in klingsmoos science und fiction herzlich willkommen
Platz für eventuelle die für die feuerwehr
feuerwehrleute retten tagtäglich menschenleben und auch besitz und allen ist klar dass das ein echt harter und wichtiger job ist mit vielen
herausforderungen und risiken feuer
toxischer rauch der kaum zu durchdringen ist und eine mehr als 20 kilogramm schwerer schutzausrüstung
Jetzt hat ein forschungsteam auslösern ein intelligentes system
entwickelt das mit einer wärmebildkamera
Kombiniertes feuerwehrleute sollen so ihre umgebung in echtzeit erfassen können selbst bei rauch und in der dunkelheit das system dient der orientierung
in unbekannten räume in denen sie opfer möglichst schnell finden und bergen müssen es ersetzt die eher unhandlich und
unpraktische wärmebildkamera und macht die hände frei konkret besteht das system aus einem transparenten bildschirm in der
sauerstoffmaske und einer mini infrarotkamera auf dem hemd die feuerwehrleute sehen so zwei bilder und zwar
Im helm vor sich das bild dass ihre eigenen augen ihnen zeigen und ziehen zudem das von der wärmebildkamera in echtzeit
aufgenommene medien bürger einer der beteiligten ingenieure sagt dazu
Wir haben nach einer optimalen lösung gesucht um heiße und kalte zonen darzustellen wir haben natürlich
Rot und blau verwendet doch wir mussten vor allem die richtigen farbtöne finden die auf einer
transparenten oberfläche sichtbar sind der prototyp wird bereits in der praxis getestet und das feedback ist gut
Im ersten moment ist es schwierig zu unterscheiden was man gerade sieht ob es real ist oder nicht aber
man gewöhnt sich erstaunlich schnell daran und kann leicht mit den beiden sich überlappenden ansichten umgehen platz drei
Notrufsystem autos rufen selbst die 112 an vielleicht haben es einigen von euch mit bekommen seit ende märz
2018 müssen alle neuwagen in der europäischen
union der eu über ein automatisches notrufsystem
verfügen sein name ecall und das wird hoffentlich sehr viele menschenleben retten
und den straßenverkehr vielleicht tatsächlich ein bisschen sicherer machen denn statistiken zufolge
Sterben täglich auf den straßen der eu so viele menschen wie der hamburger stadtteil eppendorf als einwohner hat nämlich rund
25.500
Das ecall notruf system verwendet gps und eine mobilfunkverbindung um schnell hilfe
zu holen konkret funktioniert das mit einer eingebauten sim karte durch die eine
Direkte verbindung zur rettungs nummer 112 aufgebaut wird denn die ist in ganz europa
einheitlich das geht händisch falls der fahrer dazu nach einem unfall noch fähig ist aber eben auch
Automatisch zudem sendet das auto wichtige daten an den rettungsdienst den ort des unfalls dem zeitpunkt die nummer mit der das auto
Identifiziert werden kann und auch die fahrtrichtung des unfallwagens auch die zahl der menschen die im auto
Sitzen oder saßen wird über die anzahl der gurte ermittelt und weitergegeben auch zeugen und unseren beteiligte können über die freisprechanlage
infos an den rettungsdienst
Übermitteln das ecall system musst nur um hilfe wenn die airbags ausgelöst werden so soll verhindert werden dass bei kleinen harmlosen
ein park unfällen zum beispiel
rettungsstellen umsonst alarmiert und damit unnötig überlastet werden bis zu 40 prozent weniger zeit so in städtischen regionen
Vergehen bis rettungsdienste, am unfallort eintreffen
1500 menschen leben
Könnten pro jahr gerettet werden ja wer demnächst nicht vorhat einen neuwagen zu kaufen aber dennoch nicht auf solche notrufs
assistenten verzichten wird kann auch sein älteres auto
nachrüsten lassen platz zwei
algorithmen spüren verbrecher auf wie beim 1 0 t report sind
algorithmen mittlerweile in der lage verbrechen vorherzusagen zudem sind sie in der lage die täter nach ihrer tat
aufzuspüren in deutschland wird solch eine polizeiarbeit die auf computer vorhersagen wie
predictive policing genannt in bayern und baden württemberg beispielsweise
laufen dazu
pilotprojekte eine in deutschland entwickelte software sagt voraus
wo einbrecher demnächst zuschlagen werden das ganze basiert auf der annahme dass täter nach
mustern arbeiten dass sie beispielsweise orte bevorzugen an denen es gute fluchtmöglichkeiten gibt oder aber
dass sie in erfolgreiche gebiete zurückkehren und wieder zuschlagen genau das sagt die software voraus und wenn sie sich zumindest 70 prozent sicher ist
schlägt sie erlauben dann werden polizisten an diesen ort geschickt in den usa hat sich der amerikanische journalist thomas
Hahn wurf eigenständig eine ähnliche software gebastelt über diese sind ist wirklich sensationelle arbeit hat man ja schon berichtet
er hat zunächst tatsächlich das größte mordfall archiv der usa angelegt mehr als
750.000 mordfälle hat der hierarchie wird und übertrifft damit sogar das fbi
dessen archive tatsächlich 27.000 mordfälle weniger zählen dagegen stehen etwa
220.000 ungelöste mordfälle seine konkrete idee die entwicklung einer software die
gemeinsamkeiten der verbrechen identifiziert wie wurde das opfer getötet
Wurde das verbrechen begangen und um welche opfer handelte sich alle infos zu den morden der letzten drei jahrzehnte
Wurden ins archiv aufgenommen und das computerprogramm machte sich an die arbeit
Um nach möglichen gemeinsamkeiten der unterschiedlichen mordfälle zu suchen und es klappt tatsächlich
der software beispielsweise
aufgefallen dass es in indianer 15 ungeklärte todesfälle gab und zwar mit frappierenden
gemeinsamkeiten die opfer allesamt frauen wurden allesamt erwirkt und allesamt in verlassenen häusern aufgefunden doch die polizei dort
ignorierte die hinweise von thomas adolph einen serienmörder
Im eigenen bezirk undenkbar doch der ehemalige journalist war hartnäckig
zudem passierten weitere sieben morde auch diese opfer wurden erwürgt erst dann handelte die polizei
mittlerweile sitzt der killer hinter gittern und hat weitere sechs morde gestanden
das fatale auch diese morde waren bis dahin von der polizei
Nicht als morde erkannt worden tatsächlich ein großes problem in den usa
achtung
5000 menschen töten dort pro jahr ohne
Dass sie dafür bestraft werden platz eins mit computern krankheiten besiegen wir haben ja schon mal da war
Berichtet und das ist auch echt ein ziemlich irres ding tech firmen wie amazon apple microsoft und google arbeiten tatsächlich daran
hautkrebs durch algorithmen zu diagnostizieren oder depressionen mit hilfe von software zu behandeln und
herzinfarkte durch nanopartikel
Vorherzusagen die überlegung dahinter das verständnis von krankheiten sei ein daten problem das mit hilfe von. Künstlicher intelligenz ki
Computern und algorithmen gelöst werden kann das würde nicht nur den gesamten bereich der medizin sondern tatsächlich die komplette welt
revolutionieren und hier noch ein paar konkrete beispiele aus der praxis bei amazon geht es hauptsächlich um
virtuelle arztbesuche und darum wie sich riesige datenmengen
im medizinischen bereich in einer cloud speichern lassen google möchte mit hilfe von software
depressionen heilen und herzinfarkte mit hilfe künstlicher
nano-partikel
Voraussagten wow das klingt wirklich irre und mittlerweile ist es gar nicht mehr
Nötig software zu entwickeln stattdessen entwickelt sie sich selbst so dass sie aus daten lernt so bei
microsoft projekt namens hannover computer sollen sich hierbei zunächst einmal das komplette medizinische wissen aneignen heißt also
studien lesen und verstehen
Millionen von artikeln sind ja verfügbar und täglich kommen neue erkenntnisse hinzu wie sollte ein mensch mit kommen hier unmöglich
kein großes problem dagegen für maschinen sie sollen ärzteteams in zukunft dabei unterstützen personalisierte
behandlungsmethoden zu finden computer könnten für jeden einzelnen patienten für jede einzelne patientin
individuell angepasste
medikamentencocktails finden statt einen wirtschaft nach dem anderen zu testen könnte intelligente software auf grundlage
der genomischen daten der patienten die literatur nach der perfekten medikamentenkombination
durchsuchen auf einen schlag können so tausende von kombinationen analysiert werden und dem ärzte-team
vorgeschlagen werden durch die zusammenarbeit mit dem menschen könnten die maschinen dann sogar immer weiter dazulernen und ihre intelligenz
Ausbauen eine große vision der tech firmen ist es übrigens auch die menschlichen biologie irgendwann einmal
steuern so können wir eine software dna könnte dann beispielsweise
programmiert werden ebenso wie zählen dieses einem forschungsteam der stanford university tatsächlich schon gelungen und soll nun weiter
perfektioniert werden dazu muss man verstehen wie sie funktionieren dann
So die idee ließe sich eine programmiersprache erfinden, um ihre steuerung zu übernehmen krebs in einer
Zelle ließe sich so also erkennen und der computer könnte in diesem fall das kommando selbstmord befehl natürlich nur für die krebszellen
Ibm hat eine ki entwickelt die die die dna sequenzierung eines gehirntumors schneller und zuverlässiger
analysiert hat als das gesamte team der menschlichen
expertinnen und experten in israel arbeitet ein forschungsteam an einem virtuellen
gesundheits assistenten der die patientinnen und patienten
Im chat berät die maschine hat zugriff auf eine riesige datenbank
Und allen aufnahme protokoll bei wunsch zudem auf die persönlichen daten der patientinnen und patienten
Na klar gibt es hier auch
Kritik die datenschutzprobleme werden angeprangert und ja wir müssen tatsächlich vor und nachteile sehr sorgfältig gegeneinander abgewogen werden
Wenn er als erstes neues zu bahnbrechenden erkenntnissen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp
Dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert und zur begrüßung gibt es ein kleines kuli einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genommen mit der glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter dafür auch. Draufklicken mit krebs mit smartphone
diagnostizieren ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran